c'est une signature à 15 millions
d'euros
cette convention entre le département
des yvelines et l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines porte sur la
rénovation urbaine c'est pas une commune
aujourd'hui qui peut faire face bien sûr
de tels engagements
donc heureusement le département des
yvelines vient bien sûr nous nous
accompagner nous soutenir et puis
effectivement déclenché avec ses moyens
ces opérations de rénovation dont on a
terriblement besoin dans ces quartiers
là le département veut poursuivre ce que
l'état ne fait plus l'état à
l'initiative de jean louis borloo alors
ministre d'état ministre de la ville
s'était engagée dans le renouvellement
urbain petit à petit on voit que ce qui
a été fait se dégrade et l'impatience de
ceux pour qui rien n'est fait et le
risque c'est qu'on retombe dans cette
spirale vicieuse et négatives
restructuration de gymnase
réhabilitation des espaces publics
ces opérations ont été recensés pour
cette commune et huit quartiers dont
deux à trappes
nous ça nous permet d'intervenir sur des
opérations dès maintenant et ça permet
aussi aux bailleurs d'intervenir sur
quelques opérations avaient aidé des
subventionnements élevé puisque ça
atteint 70% du montant des travaux dans
un cadre de cinq millions d'euros pour
la vue de drap ça concerne nous surtout
d'agrandissement d'écoles ou des
aménagements autour des cols parce que
c'est toujours là quand nous
travailler en priorité puis ça concerne
pergaud debussy et védrine en ce qui
concerne les lieux d'habitat la
rénovation urbaine sur saint quentin et
vienne est évalué à plus de 37 millions
d'euros
les projets doivent être lancés avant le
31 décembre 2019